chris sims having a hard time with a
play call back when he was a rookie last
night the raiders ultimately had a hard
time with the chiefs although you have
to give las vegas credit you do they had
the chiefs on the ropes multiple times
they just couldn't punch them through
and at one point i thought are they
really going to pull off a sweep
are they really going to do it are they
going to sweep the chiefs that's really
going to happen now that's that then
it's like no that's that's that's just
not going to happen not with patrick
mahomes and andy reed around it's not
going to happen no i i mean
i i was sitting there mike to your
thought going wait what great teams have
we seen through history who have
kryptonite in their own division right
and the first team that came to my mind
was like my dad with the eagles of the
late 80s early 90s right they you know
they won two super bowls but man they
couldn't beat the damn eagles twice a
year it was just brutal it is rare but
within divisional football and a guy
like john gruden and he knows who's he's
competing against he's building a team
trying to build a team that is the
kryptonite to the kansas city chiefs and
i know we'll get into it here in a
second but man there's a lot like you
said to be happy about if you're a
raider and just the
the trajectory of where their football
team and organization is going
yeah you have to feel like you're
bumping up against the ceiling but at
least you're bumping up against the
ceiling instead of sitting in the corner
staring up at it 12 feet away they are
making progress unlike the other teams
in their division so that's good news it
is pro football talk live on the monday
of thanksgiving week peacock series
11 live nbcsn if you're watching it on
the rear it's live as far as you're
concerned hello good morning hello grab
a seat grab a beverage grab a donut or
whatever and then at 7 p.m local time in
the uk and ireland grab your dinner grab
your your
what do they eat i don't know what they
eat they dinner i'm pretty sure they eat
dinner i know they eat dinner but i'm
trying to think
they may call it supper you never know
don't get me started on the whole supper
dinner thing but but uh i'm just trying
to think of a signature meal bangers and
mash right that i've always
enjoyed that although fish and chips
let's just stick with fish and chips i
think anyway hello to our friends in the
uk and ireland who have been uh uh
really locked in this season and i see
that the schedule every week it's
tweeted out by the nfl's uk
account
and i i do the i don't have to do the
math it shows the local times i'm
thinking these folks are serious the
games start at 6 00 pm 9 pm 1am and i
hear from folks there all the time
they're locked in watching all night
long what a weird kind of vampire
schedule you have to be on to follow the
nfl
they're on lockdown they're on lockdown
in the uk so they they appreciate us
they appreciate the nfl and we
appreciate them for giving
us some of their time and attention all
right let's get back to that game game
of the day chiefs and the raiders 35 31
the chiefs win the game
mahomes to kelsey to pull it out kelsey
ends up wide open and i think it's that
threat the play that we showed in the
pregame of patrick mahomes running the
ball that threat of him running sucks
the defenders toward the line and leaves
guys open and that's what contributed to
travis kelsey just kind of standing
in the end zone that the john travolta
meme from pulp fiction there's nobody
around him because uh yeah they they
abandoned him they let him go and it
looked like 15 was going to take off and
that was that lights out game over
chief's win yeah well it's jonathan
abram and i mean you said it this is
what makes patrick mahomes so dangerous
it's just the fact that he is so great
at attacking the line of scrimmage he is
sneaky dangerous when he does decide to
tuck it and run it and jonathan abrams
saw that he had all that space he's a
little getting a little scared there
right so he commits now the one thing
i'll say about that too and jonathan
abram's a hell of a player as you know
uh but there's there's there's no
timeouts at that moment right so why
commit let them let them run 10 yards
whatever
maybe 12 yards but but not not leave
travis kelsey in a huge void huge
avoided area for a guy like patrick
mahomes who we know is
the best in the league right now as far
as seeing the field as he's extending
plays i mean there's just nobody better
and yeah that was uh unbelievable
just execution and everything about that
last drive for the chiefs they're unreal
the way they can turn it on step on the
metal put the pedal to the metal and and
just make things happen in a flash
i can only imagine that any and all
planning that you engage in any effort
that you
undertake to strategize and and to be
aware going into the game you know be
aware of this be aware of that we know
what he does it all goes out the window
when you see this blur that is number 15
who is constantly eyes down the field
constantly legs on the move constantly
putting you in a position where
you're on a tightrope and you're gonna
fall off one side of the other you're
gonna give him the throw or you're gonna
give him the run and he doesn't give you
an opportunity to make that conscious
decision that your film study and your
meetings and everything you've done to
load into your brain tells you what you
need to do
but when you get out there you can't do
it it's like we talk about the scout
team quarterback trying to mimic a great
quarterback if you can do the scout team
all you want there's no replacement for
facing the guy no and there's no way to
simulate facing the guy no you're right
there is there is no way i mean some of
the the damn throws he makes out on the
edge and things like that where you go
oh they're going to push him out of
bounds he's going to get sacked what
it's a 20-yard completion
it's it's amazing and i think you know
the game itself was amazing because the
big thing i just of course the touchdown
the way they drive there at the end to
close the door i mean it's it's just
status quo really i mean i feel like
it's like hey every few weeks we get to
watch the chiefs do amazing stuff at the
end of a football game and they'll win
every time
i mean it it's but
but what's got to be disheartening you
know especially for the raiders
you play a game like that as perfect as
they played it i mean they played it
about as perfect as you can play the
kansas city chiefs and a lot of ways
match up a right way where you know we
talk about the chiefs being the ravens
kryptonite and you know other teams
being kryptonite whatever right
i mean that's what's got to be
frustrating is there on a night where
you outplay them and really kind of show
your the kryptonite to their football
team and you have the answers
schematically on both sides of the ball
and you still lose because
kansas city shows they're able to adapt
oh you want to play coverage and drop
out well we'll just take these long
drives and run and dink and dunk at dink
and dunk and it just shows the growth of
kansas city i think again and just how
dangerous they can be and how what's the
word malleable is that right where they
can just kind of change to different
and a job wow don't i hope i don't blow
a fuse because i know matt cage blew a
fuse in the box
i'm gonna take full credit for that one
because i use that word from time to
time so it shows that just kind of
hanging around hanging around somebody
who has a
better understanding the english
language although that bar is extremely
low you picked up malleable thank you
very much what about all the good
football things i said there
he said plenty of good football things
too you say plenty more good football
things than you realize although don't
put me in a position where i have to
give you credit i don't want to do that
we do have to give mahomes credit on the
run he was nine for 15 for 105 yards
that was most by quarterback this season
and and that's the baseball player in
him coming out i remember talking about
this two years ago when we first were
we're witnessing the brilliance that is
patrick with homes a brilliance to which
we've become somewhat numb and i hope we
don't get to that point where we take it
for granted i hope that doesn't help
with kyla murray i hope it doesn't
happen with patrick mahomes hope it
doesn't happen with any of the great
quarterbacks but it's the baseball it's
the shortstop yeah you don't need to
worry about all the things that
quarterback coaches obsess over with
stance and posture and mechanics and
footwork no shortstop's job is get the
ball in the glove get rid of the ball as
quickly as possible it doesn't matter
where your body is it doesn't doesn't
matter where your arm is and you're on
the run you're on the move here and i
think that that's that's why he does
what he does so flawlessly and
effortlessly
that's a short stop playing quarterback
and that's never going to change no
you're right it's not he's a wheeler and
a dealer right i mean that's what he is
a short stop you know hey double play
back you know oh this way that way
whatever feeder cockeyed like you said
sidearm throw he does it all that's what
kylo murray has too and you know and
just to
you know talk about the fact even more
he grips the the football in a very rare
way in which very few quarterbacks
really in the history the sport ever
gripped it he makes it to where it's
really got the top of the ball the
really small part and i think it's
because of what you're saying
he wants it to feel small like a
baseball so he can do those type of
things you're talking about mike and
wheel and deal and rpos and i'm gonna
pull it out and i can just flick my
wrist and throw a ten yard slant
whatever uh it just it's amazing andy
greed where they've grown as an offense
you know his maturity still at a young
age you know not being over aggressive
really taking what's there to be had all
night long and
hey as far as tv is con considered or
cons concerned
that was like one of the most fun
verbal chess matches we heard between
two quarterbacks
i think ever i mean come on all the
stuff the derek carr and patrick mahomes
were doing i mean you want to talk about
being a general they were directing more
traffic on every play last night than
any game i can remember two quarterbacks
going back and forth it was constant it
was really fun to watch
yeah and i do have to give derek carr
some credit because it almost seems like
the mahomes challenge
is pushing him to a higher level than he
otherwise would ever have been at that
in failure and in striving to match
someone you're getting more out of
yourself than when you're being pushed
from below and you know we had been
talking about the raiders with more of a
ground and pound in recent weeks not
when it's time to face the
city chiefs that's when it's time to
unleash derek carr there he is averaging
311 yards per game in the two contests
against the chief six touchdown passes
two interceptions and the only two
interceptions of the year for mahomes
coming against the las vegas raiders so
john gruden's figuring something out no
doubt when it comes to hanging with the
chiefs and you know potentially and this
is where
these games can echo beyond last night
maybe you're putting something on film
that someone else is going to
emulate or flat out copy
that that helps you in slowing down the
chiefs if you're the steelers if you're
the bills if you're somebody who's
crossing paths with them in january yeah
no i mean there's going to be certain
things that certainly will be taken from
other teams i think that we saw that
even after they lost to the raiders the
first time and i think that's why
you've seen that chief's offense evolve
to what we saw last night where chris
collinsworth is sitting there going look
derek carr's throwing it deep the chiefs
are throwing it short well yeah
i mean yeah but that's because that was
their their next chess move after that
that raiders loss in week five earlier
in the year they realized oh wow they
really took away all our deep shots they
played coverage they did a lot of good
things we need more plays to attack the
underneath area of the field when people
play us like that and they've really
grown that part of their playbook that's
where you know it's awesome to see as
far as kansas city is concerned and all
the first downs they get and the drives
i mean these aren't we're not used to
seeing them doing 12 play 91 16 play 93
they're usually like four plays 93 2
minutes and 45 seconds 35 yard touchdown
pass to cap it off by my homes that's
the kind of drives we usually see from
the chiefs so that was really impressive
and and mike back to like what you were
saying with the raiders because you said
some things that really
popped to me
i think gruden has figured them out they
are building a team as you've said all
along to compete with kansas city they
know who the kings are so they've built
a team hey good secondary good offensive
line you know can do those things and
to the other thing you said gruden
gruden cracked the code he's cracked it
with what i saw last night i could just
tell with the way him and derek carr
were talking where
he is at a spot with steve spagnolo
knowing man they're the chiefs he
studied them so hard in the offseason
and all that they were all over
some of the stuff the chiefs were trying
to do on defense you saw it all night
long it was it almost seemed like they
could not be stopped the raiders really
he had the right answer every move and
spagnola was pretty creative and smart
that way but i just know when gruden and
derek carr and just the way they were
barking out plays and talking that they
had it last night they had the feel and
that's why it's got to be discouraging
to lose a game like that
yeah they scored 71 points in two games
against the chiefs this year we talked
about this in the off season when the
broncos were loading up with receivers
the idea that you're never going to shut
the chiefs down your only way to beat
them is to fight fire with fire and make
an offense that can match up with the
kansas city defense and outscore the
kansas city offense that's the only way
you're gonna win and it happened back in
week five and it almost happened again
last night they gave them their absolute
best shot and you know we've talked
about hoping for a saints buccaneers
third game
even though the saints have swept tampa
bay this is the true rubber match
potentially if the raiders and the chief
should cross paths at arrowhead stadium
in
in uh january uh and and i'm kinda
hoping for a third match between the
raiders and the chiefs and at six and
four i mean look i know the raiders
aren't feeling good about what
ultimately happened last night they
wanted a win it would have changed
everything if they had pulled off that
victory but but they still have to when
the dust settles feel pretty good about
where they are and how far they've come
in a short period of time their first
season in las vegas with all the issues
they've dealt with yeah with all the
covet 19 the things that were
self-inflicted on themselves and the
things that they won't get in trouble
for like last week's issue with
cleveland farrell that resulted in so
many guys ending up being unavailable
because they were on the covet 19
reserve list let's hear from coach john
gruden about the struggles they faced
last week leading up to one of the
biggest challenges of the season
well it helps if we practice
you know guys show up the day of the
game it's hard to enforce these things
but i it goes back on me we've got to
get these men out on the field and
correct these problems but i couldn't be
more proud
of our football team
and i wouldn't uh i wouldn't trade any
of our players for anybody the effort
that they've given us is
tremendous
we've got to eliminate the penalties and
that starts with me
it's like he was doing an interview with
60 minutes and he did everything but
change his voice seriously i don't i
mean i i i've never seen him like that
before and i don't know whether he was
just making a statement i don't know
what he was doing a little bit about
or we just wanted to crawl in a hole
after what happened last night and that
was the next best thing to crawling in a
hole but when you don't have most of
your defense for the full week and i i
saw a report over the weekend and this
is something we joked about previously
with this notion of guys being on the
covet 19 reserve list and unable to
practice like they have a robot out
there with a with a camera on it and and
a screen so the guy you know you can sit
you know you can put the guy on the
field i guess they had laptops out there
where they were letting defensive backs
see what was going on so you do what you
have to do to try to to make guys
comfortable when they can't physically
be on the field and they've done a nice
job of that and they've got experience
at it that's the problem they had to do
with their offensive line earlier this
year that didn't work out and then they
had to do it with their defense but you
get this team into a normal year yeah
when they can have fans present when you
don't have to worry about the covet
issues uh you know i don't know is that
good for one or two wins it probably is
yeah i mean
maybe there's no doubt either way like
i think i'm sold on the fact of
the raiders are like legit playoff team
and i think a team that could make some
noise in the playoffs i do
you know first off like you said you got
to give them credit for the way they
continue to battle it's a young football
team they've thought a lot of adversity
yeah some of it is a little bit a
little of their own arrogance with covet
19 and all that definitely but man do
they play hard there's not a lot of
teams in football you can sit here and
say they've played they've beaten the
saints and the chiefs you know they lost
another game to the bucks because of
even worse circumstances with not being
able to practice because of covet and
all those issues but the way their
schedule sets up here down the stretch
and i know al and chris talked about it
last night it is
you know pretty damn good it's the
easiest in the afc
you know they can very easily
you know run off and and end up winning
five out of the last six four out of the
last six now does that get in the
playoffs here in the afc i don't know
but i do think that they're the type of
team that's built to be a pain in the
butt for just about anybody in the afc
playoffs this year but the way they run
the ball and the way like you mentioned
already derek carr and john gruden are
kind of executing that offense
and i do have to give john gurdon credit
for the work he's done without eric carr
they were legitimate and widespread
concerns three years ago
that carr and gruden would never be able
to coexist that car would crumble under
the weight of the guy that you
experienced in tampa bay but to his
credit gruden has changed his approach
deliberately and consciously because he
knew he had to make it work with carr
because even though and you have said it
before
john gruden quarterback hor der right
always looking
always smitten always infatuated with
some other quarterback it gets back to
the old steven stills song if you can't
be with the one you love love the one
you're with he loves derek carr cause
that's who he has and he's gotten the
most out of him by changing his ways and
drawing it out of car
and quietly and slowly turning him into
almost a franchise quarterback yeah i'm
not quite there yet but he's almost
there yeah i mean he he's shown a lot of
the signs he's you know as we talked
about last week with my top 10
quarterback list and all that derek carr
i you know was the next guy to me he was
at number 11. i thought it was matt ryan
uh it was those two but no it was derek
carr was number 11. i'll show you the
piece of paper but you're a funny guy he
was very close all right but either way
uh i agree with you and you know last
night really showed you
what derek carr is becoming and has
become in this this short period of time
with with john gruden i mean first off i
think you're right like gruden realized
he had to make it work he was i think
also had to realize that he was going to
have a bad reputation if it was another
quarterback where it just didn't seem to
work the right way he was teetering on
you know the line of people just going
oh he always blames the quarterback it's
always the quarterback's fault it's
never his fault blah blah blah blah well
no he hung in there with this guy and
the attitude the demeanor the control of
the offense it's exactly what gruden
wants i mean this is how he talks to you
in the meeting room quarterback meeting
room he's really got him where he wants
and you know that first time out do you
remember the first drive of the game
derek carr he's getting a little chess
match with the chiefs of the line of
scrimmage he ends up having to call time
out real quick right before it and he's
walking over there and he's going to
talk to gruden and he stops he goes i i
got it i got it like he's like i got it
don't worry yes that was a tough one
whatever i got it like i'm just gonna
stay here i don't need to go over there
and like we have to you know rehearse
life one more time and to me that showed
too that he's in a spot where he's so
comfortable he's not flustered by
anything and he can sit there and talk
and match wits with gruden about all the
x's and o's and be in a really
comfortable spot and i think that's
where they are and that's why they're
they're kind of dangerous right now
and he's developing the demeanor that
gruden is always looking for
that's that's the irony and i do think
i'm using it properly gruden is trying
to develop a quarterback who eventually
will say to gruden shut the hell up yeah
go over there and sit down oh wait oh
yeah you're standing or you're sitting i
can't tell you're so short just get out
of here and leave me alone i got this
right
so that's what he wants yes and that's
what he may have in derek carr now yeah
now all car has to do is block him on
twitter
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports